今天要分享的案例，其實一開始我看的時候，會覺得跟我們一般的生活好像有點遠，但細想之下，又覺得它把一個很常見的東西玩出了新花樣。
怎麼說呢？通常這種說法，不是什麼高科技，就是非常顛覆性的應用吧。
也不能說它完全不是高科技，但核心的概念其實很簡單。這家公司叫做 Unvault，它做的是「幫你把家裡放著沒動的珠寶首飾，變成錢」。
哦？變現的意思嗎？這點子有什麼特別？一般不是就去當舖、銀樓嗎？這算是創新嗎？
沒錯，問題就在這裡。共同創辦人 Nidhi Singhvi 發現，在美國，大家對珠寶的態度，跟她的家鄉印度很不一樣。她說「珠寶一直被愚蠢地處理」，買的時候溢價很高，想賣的時候卻只能去當舖或當地珠寶商，估價又很不透明。
所以這家公司就是讓這個過程更透明、更方便，讓大家更容易變現？這樣聽起來，其實只是優化現有服務，感覺不是那麼「哇」吧。
你猜對一半。其實他們一開始也不是直接做這個。Singhvi 在華頓商學院畢業後，先是創辦了 Sonalore，賣 18K 金飾並提供終身回購保證。但後來顧客們卻一直問：「我已經有很多珠寶了，但我不知道它們值多少錢，你們能幫忙嗎？」
嗯，這就出乎意料了。不是公司推出什麼新產品，而是顧客主動告訴他們「你們應該做這個」。
對，就是這個轉折點。Singhvi 意識到，大家其實把珠寶視為一種投資，只是不知道怎麼評估價值。於是，他們在 2025 年 6 月，成立了 Unvault，專門幫助人們估算個人黃金的價值。
好，那具體怎麼估價？總不能只靠目測吧？這點我很懷疑，黃金鑑定是很專業的。
他們有善用 AI 技術。Unvault 的 App 可以透過珠寶的照片，結合體積數據來估算價值。Singhvi 提到，因為他們本身也有做金飾的經驗，所以會疊加人工的專業知識來校正 AI 的判斷，讓結果更精準。
AI 加上人為校正，這點我是信了。畢竟 AI 還在發展中，需要有專業的人去監督。那除了估價，還有其他服務嗎？
當然。顧客很快就表示想直接在平台上賣珠寶。Unvault 就在上線一個月內，迅速增加了銷售功能。客戶會把珠寶寄到他們的郵政信箱，Singhvi 甚至會自己去收件。
喔，把高價值商品寄給一個線上平台？這點我很疑惑。萬一寄丟了、出問題了，誰負責？這信任感怎麼建立？
這就是 Unvault 關鍵的創新點之一：透明度。他們在整個銷售流程中提供全程錄影，從打開包裹、到用 X 光機測試黃金純度，客戶都能看到。甚至會細到告訴你這條是 17.34K 金，每個品項都有獨立報價和費用明細。
全程錄影，這個做法很有意思，確實能建立很大的信任感，打消客戶的疑慮。但這樣的模式能撐多久？畢竟還要面對矽谷那些想投資「兆元公司」的投資人吧？
沒錯，這也是他們遇到的挑戰。有投資人質疑，珠寶首飾能做到兆元級別嗎？甚至有人說女性不戴珠寶了。但 Singhvi 回應說，珠寶其實是比農業還早存在的「OG 資產類別」，女人就算只戴幾件，那也是幾千美金的價值。
我猜啦，他們能做到今天超過 1.5 億美元的資產活化，肯定證明了市場的存在。那如果我們這些創業者或中小企業主管，可以從中學到什麼？
我覺得，最值得學習的就是他們「傾聽客戶」這點。原本是要賣金飾，結果客戶告訴他們另一個需求，他們就立刻轉向，創造出更大的價值。很多時候，商機可能就藏在客戶抱怨或沒被滿足的需求裡。
這點其實不容易做到，因為很多公司都只專注在自己的產品，不太會去想客戶真正的「痛點」。那對於一般上班族來說呢？這個概念能用在生活或工作上嗎？
我覺得，可以把「隱藏財富」這個概念延伸到自己身上。比如，你是不是也有一些被忽略的技能、知識或人脈？是不是可以盤點一下，然後用更透明、更有效的方式去活化它？
嗯，有點像是在工作中，那些看似重複、無趣的資料，如果能用新的方式整理分析，說不定也能挖掘出新的價值。
沒錯。透過一個出乎意料的視角，從看似無用的地方，創造出巨大的價值。這好像也提醒了我們，很多時候，所謂的「寶藏」並不是不存在，而是我們還沒學會如何去發現它。